[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's time to
swim for your life with the release of
crawl and new horror that puts some of
the world's most dangerous animals
directly in your home throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about crawl it's
ending as well as the extra scene that
was cut in the movie there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't seen the
film yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly suggest that you
turn off now with that out the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into my
breakdown of crawl crawl follows Haley
Keller who after receiving a call from
his sister about a category 5 hurricane
heading towards her father's home goes
directly into the storm rescue mission
Haley's father Dave has been living
there since his divorce with Haley's
mother which she carries a lot of guilt
over this is because Haley is trying to
become a professional swimmer which
hopefully comes in handy a and her
father who coached her pretty much
sacrifices marriage that she could
succeed when Haley arrives at the house
she descends into the crawlspace under
it which is where she finds her father
and something else along with him giant
ravenous alligators which have managed
to infiltrate the house and give a whole
new meaning to the reason you should
never smile at a crocodile duck jock
doesn't even work I'm sorry anyway due
to the Gators size they managed to hide
between the pipes underlying the house
however as the hurricane intensifies the
basement bloods and the two have to
navigate their way out of there all
while surviving the jaws of death it's a
really unique and interesting premise
that I definitely found myself going
with early on and there's one thing that
this movie is from the off which is
tense
it doesn't really let up and you always
feel like there's a ticking clock to
everything whether it comes from the
approaching storm the flooding or the
alligators who want nothing more than a
hot meal from the beginning this is a
clear metaphor for global warming and
how else we are happy to play ignorant
when
to the welfare of the planet the danger
that mother nature brings will
eventually come into our homes and in
one way or another uproot us from it it
really feels like a modern horror
premise however it still packs all of
the underlying motifs from classic
monster movies such as jaws and the like
which really elevate this above most
there's a real sense of claustrophobia
to crawl that massively makes every
interaction with the creatures feel ever
more dangerous there's no ocean to swim
about in here just cramped ceilings and
walls and it makes the piece have an
underlying tension throughout after
several failed escape attempts and one
which shows why it's bad to go looting
Haley makes her way to the storm drain
and discovers that the alligators have
made their nest there she manages to
kill one using a gun that was picked off
a police officer and makes it to the
upstairs part of the house which allows
her to free her father they're not home
safe yet though and the house itself
begins to flood as the eye of the
hurricane sets its sights on them joined
by sugar their trusty dog the trio
managed to make their way through the
house and Haley is able to send out a
distress signal unfortunately the
alligators are hot on their tail but
Haley manages to make it to the roof
after trapping one in the shower burning
one with a player and swimming outside
the house to bring her father up there
Haley Flags down a chopper and in the
end her father watches on proudly
knowing that all the amazing coaching
that ruined his marriage his life and
his relationship with his children has
meant that Haley as the fastest swimmer
in the ocean the film abruptly cuts to
black and we don't really get any
closure though it is heavily implied
that the two made it out alive in an
interview with cinema blend Kaya
Scodelario Hobart pronounced out right
who played Haley said that this was done
intentionally and once there was
originally a cut today Ben Haley safe in
the hospital this was done for the
following reasons I always thought that
quick cut was quite clever because I
kept expecting the cut too Haley and
Dave in the hospital bed I really like
that you just on this journey and that's
all you get to see and that you here for
this experience and this thrill ride and
it doesn't let up it doesn't stop until
the credits roll there's something quite
exciting about it after I saw it I kind
of needed 20 minutes to calm down after
it because I felt exhausted and I think
that's the pace that Alex wanted to keep
personally I do agree with this and
while initially when watching it I fell
was quite abrupt it makes sense in
retrospect as it doesn't really allow
the pace of the movie to let up this
also ties into the cut scene from the
film which gave a more in-depth
backstory to Dave and his wife's divorce
dave was in the process of selling the
house in order to carry out his end of
the divorce
however he backed out of the sale
because it means so much to him this
kind of gives more motive it's why I
decided to stay there during the
hurricane and also fills in the
breakdown of his marriage I do however
think no that due to potential pacing
issues that removing it was the right
decision and it allows the film to not
really let up from its opening to the
end overall I do think cutting it
actually makes the movie better and it
was the correct decision to make as we
don't really need this section added in
order to help with the plot development
but what did I think of the movie
overall well crawl surprised me in more
ways than one this is a really engaging
horror that feels like a roller coaster
ride from beginning to end
I've never been to Florida but I can
imagine that this will really resonate
with locals there as the tension and
scenario is unique and feels like an
intense situation throughout there are
some minor criticisms I have around the
film such as the realism of the animals
and some of the CGI effects however
nothing really took me out of it and it
feels like a home run for what it does
overall this is a really enjoyable
horror that you should definitely check
out this weekend and that's why it gets
an 8 out of 10
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on Krall and if you enjoyed the movie as
much as I did comment below and let me
know and if you like this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my full breakdown of the
alternate ending of Spider Man far from
home would you be linked at the end we
go over in full detail the cutscenes of
the movie so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more I
also just want to let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of
Avengers and game on blu-ray to one
lucky winner and all you have to do is
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on crawl in the comments
section below the winner will be chosen
at random on August
and the blu-ray will be shipped out from
then to ever get surprised so best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
the channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you